well if you think it's bad that they
made you stand up can you believe
they're making me stand up here for this
whole talk hey everyone my name is Tara
and today I'm gonna ask you to use your
imagination to think about the web in a
way that maybe you never have before and
what I'm gonna ask you to imagine is a
web without servers now if your
immediate reaction is confusion or
skepticism that's okay because it
doesn't make much sense in the context
of how the web works today but hopefully
if I tell you a bit about my background
and what I work on now it will all start
to come together my name is tara van cyl
and I'm a web developer that can mean a
lot of different things but for me it
basically means I spend most of my time
thinking about the web or building
things on the web I'm also really
interested in peer-to-peer protocols and
I love anything to do with nails so if
you have an interest in nail art or nail
polish we should definitely talk later
the web is a huge part of my life now
but that wasn't always the case
I actually didn't grow up online my
family didn't have a computer and we
lived in a rural area with spotty
internet so my only access to computers
was at school where we mostly used them
for learning how to type
now I dig it on to Facebook MySpace and
sparknotes in my teenage years but my
online experiences were mostly about
consuming things I was pretty much just
looking at pictures of my crush and
catching up on the book I didn't read
for English class it wasn't until much
much later when I learned about the
existence of HTML Javascript and CSS
that I realized that I could build
things on the web this was just
something I had never considered before
I assumed that building websites was
reserved for super talented programmers
and this was a really really exciting
moment for me because it totally changed
my conception of what the web was and
how I could participate on it but I
eventually realized that after learning
how to put together a web page with HTML
there was an important question that I
needed to answer which was how do I
share the thing
that I'm building well thankfully the
inter answer to that question is really
simple you just install webpack with npm
configure web packs set up your local
dev server and bundle your app and then
ssh into a server that you've already
setup on AWS okay so it's actually not
that simple
now to be clear I'm just poking fun at
web pack I'm not one of those people who
thinks that tools are complex and bad
I actually think tools are pretty
awesome because they help us build
things and it doesn't really matter
which tool you pick as long as it helps
you build something that a browser can
understand whether you write a simple
HTML file or build something a bit more
complex your choice is valid the point
is that composing web pages is flexible
and forgiving there's room for the most
beginner beginner and the most expert
expert to build something meaningful and
I think that's part of what makes the
web such an awesome tool set but when I
was a beginner it was actually kind of
burdensome to build and especially to
share things on the web and I can tell
you it wasn't the tools that made me
feel that way
it was servers no I mean this in the
nicest way possible but servers suck and
I think I feel this way because I
started building things on the web in
this sweet spot period when Geocities
had already been shut down
but tools like net liffe I now and
Glitch didn't exist yet github pages was
around but I wasn't comfortable working
with git at that point so as far as I
could tell the best option for me to
share the web sites I was making was to
set up a server and this is pretty
frustrating for me because I didn't have
the time the expertise or frankly the
money to do that and really who does
there's like a super tiny sliver of the
human population who knows how to set up
a server and let alone enjoys doing it I
know how to run servers now and don't
get me wrong there are days that I'm in
the mood to play with nginx or let's
encrypt but most of the time it's the
very last thing I want to do and I'm
sure some people in this room are pretty
good at running servers but I don't
think it's fair to expect the rest of
the world to be
there are three billion people on the
internet today and that number is only
going to grow and they're using tools
like Facebook Instagram and WeChat to
connect and I think that's pretty
awesome
because we're seeing human connection at
a scale that was once unimaginable but I
think it's fair to say that the vast
majority of these people are never going
to participate in the web outside of the
bounds of these tools the post tweets
will share life updates on Facebook or
they'll share pictures of Berlin Street
cats on Instagram but will never craft
an HTML page will never make a fan site
for their favorite band we'll never get
to experience the creative joy of
building something on the web that's
truly theirs and I think we have to sit
with that and think really hard about
whether or not that's okay maybe it is
maybe not everybody wants to learn how
to build websites but I think we should
be certain that the web itself doesn't
get in the way of those who do and
personally I'm afraid that it does
I'm afraid that publishing on the web is
a bottleneck that something as simple as
sending an HTML file to a friend is far
too complicated I mean think about it if
you're new to the web you can spend
months and months wrapping your head
around how to write an HTML page how to
vertically Center divs or how to
navigate the latest JavaScript
frameworks and after all of that you've
gained your bearings you have some
confidence and maybe you've built
something you're proud of you still have
to figure out servers and I just think
the web can do better in fact I think
it's essential that the web do better
because of the barrier to entry remains
this high I'm afraid to think about what
the web looks like in 10 or 20 years
remember the web has only been around
since 1990 and we're already seeing the
early stages of what happens when most
people use a handful of platforms to
participate so how does this play out
for the long term what does it look like
if 28 years from today most people are
still using a tool like Facebook or
WeChat or Instagram to contribute to the
web will it still
the web or will those providers have
shaped it into something entirely
different I don't know but it seems
plausible and I don't think that is a
risk we should be willing to take
because the web is too precious I mean
it's this weird social experiment where
we've built a global language for
building things how cool is that at the
very least I think a web like this looks
kind of boring to me if you're here last
year you might remember that one of our
MCS Rachel white gave a talk called keep
the internet weird and I love this talk
I interpreted it as Rachel's love letter
to the kind of creativity that the web
inspires when communities are nice and
tools are accessible she called back to
the days of Geocities and angel fire
when there were several tools available
for folks to just jump into a browser
write HTML and publish a website for
free but you might know that Geocities
was shut down in 2009 and it took 38
million user created sites with it the
Internet Archive put up a valiant effort
to save a lot of those sites and
thankfully they were able to save some
of the precious gifts that came out of
the geo cities era but they weren't able
to save all of those 38 million sites
they're gone I think the coming and
going of Geocities and the rise of its
spiritual successors like neo cities and
glitch tell us something really
important about the web and especially
about what's missing from it I think it
tells us that setting up a server is so
far out of reach for most people that
they simply can't do it and then they
instead have to rely on tools like this
now I love neo cities I love glitch in
fact I think they're doing some of the
most important work on the web right now
but we've been here before
neo cities and glitch Hulka help us
circumvent the fact that publishing on
the web is difficult but I think we
should be asking why is it so damn
difficult in the first place and what
can we do to make it easier in a way
that has the kind of longevity we expect
out of the web platform
I think we can make it easier and I want
to share with you my vision of what that
might look like I want to ask what if we
just didn't need servers to share a
website what if we could press a button
in our browser and with one click create
a new web page well that would certainly
be nice but how in the world could we
pull that off
well we have these pretty powerful
devices we have our phones we have our
laptops right maybe we could just turn
them into servers sadly it's not that
easy there's a lot that's wrong with
this idea but to put it simply our
personal devices are just not built to
be servers first of all we shut them off
sometimes whether it's because we've
gone to sleep or the battery's dead they
don't always have a dedicated IP address
and they're just simply not built to
handle the kind of traffic that servers
to imagine publishing a video from your
personal computer and having it go viral
your computer would be flooded with
millions of requests and your home
network would probably fall over in a
few minutes so if this idea of one-click
publishing is going to work we have to
think outside of the server box because
again our personal devices just are not
servers luckily some smart people flip
this problem on its head and have found
a way for regular devices to do the
sorts of things that servers do without
actually needing to be a server
BitTorrent was created in the early
2000s by Bram Cohen and it's what you
call a peer-to-peer network the towards
key innovation was to ask what if
instead of one computer a server
handling all of the responsibility for
hosting files what if we split up that
responsibility across a network of a
bunch of different computers so that any
device could hop onto the network and
contribute some bandwidth and maybe some
of those devices are server like devices
that live up in the cloud and surely
sometimes some devices will go offline
but the big idea is that regular devices
can help contribute resources to hosting
files on a network
and this was a really big deal now I'm
sure most of you know of BitTorrent
because of its infamy it was used
largely for downloading elite movies and
music and other media illegally but I
want to point out that it's a really
crowd incredible innovation that has
tons of other legal and legitimate use
cases most importantly being that it
made it possible for regular people with
regular devices to be able to host files
and I just think that's so cool so what
if we took this approach and we applied
it to the web web sites are just files
after all and if a website is just a
collection of files then what if we
could use one of these peer-to-peer
networks to get a website from one
computer to another well it turns out
you can and I'm really excited to tell
you more about that I work with these
two guys P Frazee and matthan Tosh
they're actually both here today so if
you want to introduce yourself I'm sure
they would enjoy that and together the
three of us work on a project called the
beaker browser beaker is an experimental
browser which means that we don't always
follow web standards but it's not
because we don't think they're important
it's just that we have a few experiments
in mind that we wanted to run and we
think they're worthwhile to run even
though they're not standards compliant
and the core experiment we're running is
what happens when you take one of these
peer-to-peer networks and you put it
inside of a browser so we wanted to keep
the web mostly the same keep the browser
pretty familiar but make it peer-to-peer
and we're in a really lucky position to
be able to do this experiment because
Macintosh is actually the core developer
of a peer-to-peer protocol called that
dad is pretty similar to BitTorrent but
it's got some key improvements that make
it really well-suited for the kinds of
things we do on the web so we took that
and we put it into the browser and put
it into beaker we found out that some
really interesting things happened like
enabling one-click publishing giving
view source some cool new capabilities
and making it possible to provide new
web api's for to developers so why don't
I show you
okay this is beaker I apologize that the
tabs in the URL bar are a little small
I'll try to pint point out what's
important well in first glance it
probably looks pretty similar to any
browser that you're familiar with it's
not really remarkable in that regard
before I show you anything really
exciting why don't I just show you what
a peer-to-peer web site looks like this
is my website and you might notice that
instead of HTTP the protocol in the URL
is dead
it's really small but just trust me
that's what it says and it looks pretty
much like you would expect a web site to
look like links luck work just like you
would expect two images work just the
same as they do in other browsers and so
does CSS this was all an intentional
choice on our part we didn't want it
totally upend the web we just wanted to
see what would happen if we put a
peer-to-peer protocol into it so this
looks pretty unremarkable but I actually
think it's really cool because the files
that compose my website actually live on
my computer they're being hosted by my
computer and actually they're being
hosted by whoever else is visiting my
computer right now there's only two
people hosting it because I'm not very
popular but if there were more all of
those peers would be contributing some
bandwidths to help keep my website
online okay I promised I would show
one-click publishing let's take a look
at how this works
well because we have a peer-to-peer
protocol at our disposal we don't need a
server to do this we can literally
literally just treat this device kind of
like a server but not actually so I'm
gonna jump to beakers main menu I'm
gonna click this button that says create
new and I'm going to click the website
template we could also make an empty
project or import an existing one but
I'm gonna use this template for the sake
of time and what just happened here is
that beaker minted a brand new website
it's pretty simple it's just got some
information about how to get started you
can change the background color here
nothing too fancy but what I think is
really exciting to point out is that
this website has its own URL I could
share this URL with any of you and if
you were
open it and beaker because the only ones
that support this you could download the
website right from my computer there's
no server involved here now this URL is
not very pretty you couldn't remember it
just like IP addresses are pretty tricky
to remember as well so how might a URL
like this work with the domain name
system turns out it works out pretty
nicely and I set up a website to show
you how that works this is the Jas Kampf
EU subdomain on my personal website and
I was able to get this nice name using
just a txt record I set this up with my
domain registrar Google and I pointed
the subdomain to the long ugly URL and
that's all it took I didn't have to fuss
with any servers to get that nice URL um
I promised I would also show you view
source so why don't we take a look at
what that is like in beaker what we're
seeing here is all of the files that
compose the website we were just looking
at you can see the favicon here we can
take a look at the styles and of course
we can see the HTML that we were just
looking at these files live on my
computer and if they live on my computer
shouldn't I be able to edit them yeah
you can we've made it possible to
actually edit files inside of you source
so I can click this button right here
and what I'm going to do is add a few
exclamation points to this heading and
when I save it and go back to that tab
we'll see those changes just like that
okay that's pretty cool but we're all
developers and we probably have
preferences about our editing
environments right we've some of us like
sublime some like vs code and again
these files around my computer computer
so I could just open them up in my
preferred editor but before I do that I
want to turn on a cool little feature we
have live reloading and I'm gonna jump
over it's at the top I want to jump over
to the view source tool again I'm
actually just gonna copy the path to
where those files are on my computer and
I could open those files up and I want
to open the index.html file and I'm
going to say hello from sublime now as
soon as I click Save and head back over
to that tab we should see this change
without needing to refresh and that's
just a fun little tool
okay so I showed you one-click
publishing I showed you some of the new
things that we enabled in view source
but I haven't told you anything about
the new web api yet and before I do that
I want to give a little bit about
backstory about why we thought this was
necessary so when we first started
building beaker we were really happy
with the fact that we actually could
pull off one click click publishing but
we also realized that the web is not
just a collection of static websites
although it might be a nicer place if it
were so we thought is there any way we
can recreate the kind of behavior
behavior that apps on the web use do we
using just a peer-to-peer network so
could we use could we make it possible
to do user profiles or databases or
anything like that
the answer is yes because if you think
about it a database or a user profile is
typically just represented with files
right and if websites are also just
files then maybe we can represent user
data and user profiles inside of
websites and that's exactly what we and
some other people who are building on
these tool sets are experimenting with
this is a profile JSON file and this is
real this is actually part of a profile
that I use on a peer-to-peer social
media site and you can see that the
properties are my name my bio and my
avatar and I think it would just be
easier if I show this later to really
make it sink in so if we're gonna make
it possible for developers to build
peer-to-peer apps that use user data we
need to make sure that they can actually
read that data and write it and so
that's why we provided some new web
api's and they look a little bit like
this but again I think this is easier if
I just show you so I'm gonna jump into
the console on this website here and
let's see I'm going to start out by
getting a website an object that
represents this dat website that we're
on and I'm gonna use this do this using
the debt archive api's that we have and
beaker and why don't you do window dot
location
and we now have this object and we can
do a lot with it but I just want to show
you one thing which is that we can write
a new HTML file to this website so we're
gonna have a website writing to itself
okay so website dot write file I'm gonna
call it API dot HTML and I'm just gonna
write some simple markup to it and I'm
gonna use autocomplete because I'm a
cheater
okay so we've written the file and now
if we go to API that HTML we can see
that we've created a new HTML file so it
might not be totally intuitive at first
what all this enables but it actually
enables a lot we have a whole social
media application using these api's to
write user profiles it's looks a bit
like Twitter you might have noticed and
that was intentional we wanted to see if
we could replicate a lot of the behavior
that Twitter provides so we have a feed
we can look at people's posts we can
like posts and reply to them of course
and I think I will actually say hello
from Jan Scott and anybody who is
following me will sync these changes
from my profile ok now I actually want
to show you my profile this is pretty
neat I think so this is an index.html
cover page I have but I want to show you
what I mean by saying putting user data
and user profiles into into websites
these are all of my posts and you can
see the the objects that represent my
posts are pretty simple it just has some
text and a timestamp and if this were a
post I had if this were a reply it would
also contain some information about who
I was replying to um I think this is so
cool because some interesting things
happen when you separate user data from
the application layer the application in
this case is just sort of a view on top
of my profile and over top of all of my
friends profiles
and what this means is that the app and
the data are no longer tied together so
I can actually customize the app with
little consequence so let's just do that
and see how that would work I'm gonna
open this up and view source and I don't
own this website so I can't just edit
them I have to have to make a copy so
I'm gonna go ahead and make a copy and I
don't like that fritter this app has
round buttons I want to make them square
so I'm gonna jump into the CSS file here
and I'm just going to search for the
button class aha here's the border
radius and I want to get rid of will
save it and we're gonna open this up
we're gonna see an entirely new social
media application and we can see that
the buttons are now square no I
I haven't given this specific instance
of app permission to write to my profile
that's why it looks a bit different but
if I were to select my profile and load
everything up I wouldn't lose any of my
friends I wouldn't lose my network or my
content or anything and even though this
change I made was kind of trivial you
can imagine being in a situation where
on social media where a change you'd
like to make is not trivial maybe you'd
like to have some say over how the color
scheme works because you are colorblind
or maybe you want better moderation
tools you're empowered to do that with
this model and I think that's just
fantastic now I'm not going to make any
promises that this type of model a
peer-to-peer web is going to fix
everything that's wrong with the web and
I'm not gonna promise that an app like
fritter is going to ever become as
popular as Facebook or Twitter because
they're already pretty darn popular but
I can promise that a peer-to-peer web
does make apps like this possible and I
can say that with confidence because I
use fritter every single day and so do a
lot of my friends if you want to learn
more about beaker um please just talk to
me afterwards I'm really excited to
share more about it or you can visit any
of these links to learn more and I want
to just end with this and say that I
think fundamentally a peer-to-peer web
is a more fun web that no matter what
your technical expertise is or your
access to resources it's a web you can
contribute you can build and you can
share and I think that makes it a
worthwhile experiment to run not just in
beaker but in every single browser thank
you so much for imagining with me